okay so let's just get this sorted right
off the bat a National Geographic
article estimates that it's Rama Soros
Rex's top speed is about 12 miles an
hour any faster and it's bones would
have shattered in 2013 a woman ran
100-meter dash in heels in a
record-breaking 14.5 3-1 seconds or
about 15 point 4 miles an hour so well
it may not be easy it would be entirely
feasible to outrun a t-rex in heels to
all that buzz around Claire Dearing
doing it in Jurassic world a hundred
percent laws about the real question is
why are you driving so slow
[Music]
hello internet welcome to theory Park
about a month or two ago I asked you all
on Instagram at matpat GT by the way
whether you'd be interested in a
Jurassic world theory and overwhelmingly
you all said yes so today as an early
Kwanzaa gift we'll be sticking our noses
into one of the most overlooked aspects
of the movie the plot the whole thing
seems pretty straightforward right in
djenne mixes a bunch of genes together
to create the freakshow of death known
as the I Rex or should I say Verizon
Wireless presents the indominus rex
hashtag not spotted all there guys it's
like the emoji movie all over again I
Rex is too smart for them and escapes
only to have big dinos running around
eating people for a second time in any
of these parks and humanity still flocks
to these deathtrap parks it's a miracle
that we don't lose the race for survival
of the fittest then again I guess a
two-hour think piece on the ethics of
dinosaur cloning legislation would be a
terrible movie Jurassic Park
Jurassic world Jurassic United Nations
anyway while everyone else watching
these movies loses their minds over
whether the kids are gonna become a
velociraptors amused bouche I'm losing
my mind over the science because well
the Jurassic movies deal with some
fascinating concepts like genetics
splicing and cloning in Jurassic world
it actually goes one step further if you
stop and analyze the science in the
movie you on earth a fascinating and
completely undiscovered plot line that
recontextualizes everything that you're
watching unfold on screen because here's
the truth
the IREX doesn't escape on its own the
whole thing was a setup the dinosaur had
hell let's look at the way the IREX
escape happens in the movie during a
routine check up on the indominus to
infrared cameras monitoring its pen
reveal no heat
this coupled with claw marks against the
walls lead the team to think that the
indominus rex has escaped
despite the potentially huge security
breach and the ability to call up the
control room and check on the dinos
tracker location in a matter of seconds
Chris Crabb decides to just saunter on
into the pen only to find out that
whoops the AI Rex had hit its heat
signature from the cameras and was still
in there he done got full as the humans
try to escape they leave the door open
for the AI Rex to escape and in the
process set in motion the hilarious line
of dominoes where by the end practically
every dinosaur is out knowing on the
bones of innocent tourists and all they
wanted to do was just educate themselves
about the Mesozoic era now that all begs
the question of how one dinosaur
genetically modified her--not was able
to hide its heat signature from infrared
cameras and lurid zookeepers into a
death trap well according to the beasts
creator dr. Henry Wu hen we woo well
according to the beasts creator dr.
Henry Wu the genetic cocktail that makes
up the eye Rex gave the creature some
really cool superpowers like the ability
to cloak itself and the ability to alter
its body heat cuttlefish chains were
added to help her withstand an
accelerated growth rate tree frogs can
modulate their infrared output we use
strands from their DNA to adapt her to a
tropical climate in order for the eye
Rex to evade both visual and infrared
detection to trick its captors into the
cage it would have had to have used both
those abilities at once the problem is
that is scientifically impossible dr. Wu
is absolutely right that cuttlefish can
change the chromatophores on their skin
to create a kind of camouflage and
honestly it is super impressive and he's
also right that tree frogs can modulate
their infrared output through their
control of body heat so for someone
lightly versed in animal biology this
explanation totally holds up but there's
one huge problem here the eye Rex could
not use both abilities at the same time
you see the way the tree frog regulates
their body temperature is by changing
colors darker colors tend to absorb more
light causing body heat to increase
while lighter colors reflect more light
cooling off the Frog or in this case
mutant dinosaurs that's all well and
good if you don't care how visible you
are but if you're currently trying to
camouflage yourself to match your
surroundings and avoid visual
tection who don't also have the luxury
of adjusting your body heat the same way
a tree frog does dr. wu is either just
flat-out wrong about the science the
IREX is putting to use or he's lying oh
so just cuz I know it's gonna come up in
the comments the fact that everyone
reminds us that IREX can pass a
consensus thermal radiation like snakes
doesn't disprove anything yes snakes can
sense heat signatures they practically
have their own built-in thermal vision
that they use while hunting but that's
not gonna do all that much to help a
hybrid Dino disappear from a bunch of
surveillance cameras the only way for
the IREX to hatch this entire plan on
its own is if one it was able to sense
the electromagnetic waves coming from
the cameras in its pen two it had the
knowledge those cameras were tracking
its heat signature three it had figured
out the exact range and sensitivity of
those cameras and four it somehow was
able to make the connection that those
cameras were specifically being used by
the humans to monitor and even if the
indominus had human DNA in its genetic
cocktail to give it super intelligence
we know based on a back door in the must
Ronnie blog an additional site made by
the movies supposedly written by the CEO
of the park that you can hack into it's
actually a really cool idea that the
movie developed in anticipation of the
launch that the CEO gave the orders to
start development of the dinosaur in
2012 this movie takes place in 2015 at
the absolute most the IREX is three
years old
no three year old human or otherwise
it's gonna be smart enough to concoct
the AI Rex's plan so what Hollywood just
drop the ball and another series of
scientific facts that's nothing new but
in this case I don't think it was a
mistake at all if you look closer the
evidence points to the cameras having
been tampered with by who well the
obvious choice is Vic Hoskins head of
engine security division throughout the
movie he repeatedly expresses his desire
to give the Raptors a field test to
prove that they could be effective
weapons in war what do you need buddy
field test
look nature gave us the most effective
killing machines 75 million years ago
Jets it's grown-up time only his request
is repeatedly denied by the CEO of the
company who shows no signs of changing
his mind despite all the years of work
Hoskins has put into the program I've
been working for two years on an
application for those Raptors they can
hunt and kill that creature let me be as
clear as I can no one lost adapters are
going to be setting loose it's only
after the IREX escapes and the CEO dies
trying to recapture it that Vic is able
to take control of the park and finally
get the field test he was demanding he
sabotages the system so the iris can
escape and he gets his field test when
everyone else denied him everything
lines up everything except for one line
he's surprised when the IREX escapes
hey yeah it's me we might have an
opportunity here so it may not have been
Vic there was one other person involved
with this conspiracy that also stands to
benefit from the field test the creator
of the I Rex and most of the other dinos
in the park the secret villain of the
entire series dr. Henry at the end of
the film
Hoskins begins revealing his plan only
to get himself rudely interrupted he
should have had Henry breed in some
etiquette there Vic but before he
becomes just a meat flick between some
Raptor teeth he confirms that dr. woo
wasn't working for MS Ronnie in the park
rather engine and its goal of developing
dinosaurs as weapons dr. rue he works
for us somebody's got to make sure that
this company has a future in fact as Woo
evacuates the island in the engine
helicopter we hear him specifically ask
he's saving you in the SS to a secure
location
dr. Wu clearly had a deal with Vik
Hoskins tied to the iraq's but it's
likely that that deal was contingent on
proving the combat effectiveness of the
dinosaur and there was no way to do that
while it was locked inside of its panic
they had to find a way to release it but
why why would we want this chaos well
remember a recurring theme through the
whole movie is that the park is quickly
losing money in the clip we just saw Vic
said how he's ensuring that the company
has the future the opening moments have
the employees including dr. Wu trying to
win over potential investors and in the
first conversation with the parks owner
the CEO just completely brushes aside
any financial concerns about cost the
company is going downhill fast
while year-over-year revenue continues
to climb operating costs are higher than
ever our shareholders have been patient
but let's be honest no one's impressed
by a dinosaur
dr. Wu sees himself as a scientific
genius office exists because of him and
from the secret website files we learned
that he received international fame the
last time he created a genetic hybrid
and that was only him creating a plant
in short dr. Wu sees himself as a god
that's not me talking that is literally
the name of the book that he wrote the
next step and evolution of God's
concepts but all that goes away if the
company goes away no more job equals no
more research equals no more faith he
sees the writing on the wall he sees
investments in the amusement park down
costs rising and the CEO being
unconcerned about all of it so he
started to make alternate plans a deal
with Vick Hoskins and higher-ups at
engine to not only secure his own future
but more importantly the future of his
research except all of it hinged on a
real-life test of the dinosaurs a test
that only happened because one of those
dinosaurs found some miraculous
unbelievable way of escaping or maybe it
was Wow himself making that miracle
happen helping to give the indominus the
little push it needed to escape which
brings us all the way back around to the
science remember it's dr. Wu who comes
up with the false science behind how the
AI Rex manages to escape the man is a
brilliant geneticist if he knows that
tree frogs can modulate their
temperature he knows that it depends on
the frogs coloration he knows that the I
Rex couldn't evade both types of cameras
now look at how this moment is shot whoo
and has his back to Miz Ronny it's
clearly a purposeful choice because in
this moment dr. Wu is absolutely lying
he's the one who sabotaged the cameras
allowing the indominus rex to escape
moving that the scariest monster in
Jurassic world is mankind itself but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut by the way you know how animals are
pretty much all either warm-blooded like
mammals or cold-blooded like reptiles
well right now scientists think that
dinosaurs might be in the middle
slightly able to regulate their own body
temperature it's actually called mezzo
thermic sea turtles a few sharks can
also do it apparently anyway I just
thought it was a funny thing to bring up
since means that
i Rex would just be able to modulate its
body temperature naturally none of this
weird genetic splicing explanation
necessary anyway speaking of dinosaurs
take a big ol bite out of that subscribe
button where you can bet that I have
more theories on the way as we get
closer to the next Jurassic movie coming
next year hey if you want more Dino
analysis well then check out my game
theory on Jurassic world where I examine
whether you could actually clone a
dinosaur from DNA extracted from amber
the answer is gonna surprise you now if
you'll excuse me I'm starting to feel a
little bit of Jurassic if you get what
I'm saying so I'm gonna lay down
hopefully I feel better for next week
see you then